hey what's up guys my name is Jenna
welcome to episode 112 of game
programming we are back it has been like
over six months I think probably at
least close to that which is absolutely
ridiculous but we're back and hopefully
I'm gonna start pumping out video it's a
bit more often for you guys so obviously
there is no I was away I was because of
University and whatnot I'm back I'm sure
it's the holidays and I'm actually not
just gonna be studying next year I'm
gonna be working so that's a bonus as
well basically there should be a lot
more videos and so don't get too mad at
me okay I'm sorry but you know I did
what I had to do okay anyway I promised
you guys we would do sprite rotation so
I mean I can't just come back here after
not making videos and break my promises
so we're gonna be doing sprite rotation
today
now few things on what you guys to
realize is the sprite rotation is not
going to be it's not gonna look
completely flawless and it is going to
be slightly difficult to implement okay
which is fine we can do it okay I know
we can but just keep that in mind okay
and one of the reasons is if we take a
look at our sprites right so if you go
into your resources folder in your
project and go to something like let's
just say textures because the main thing
we're gonna use this for is projectiles
right so all these for now at least so
in textures shades projectiles if you
look at our wizard projectile or if you
just look at our projectiles in general
let's just edit this right and you know
beloved paint.net you'll see that um
we're dealing with pretty low resolution
graphics okay we are dealing with fairly
low resolution graphics so what we're
gonna do right now is create a
projectile froster rotate if we rotate
this thing we're barely gonna see any
difference right it's basically a circle
I mean we are gonna see a bit of
difference obviously and there is this
thing here and it's not you know it's
not completely it's not really you know
if we rotate it on 45 degrees or
whatever there will be a bit of a
difference but let's just draw something
that we can actually see in action like
a line basically we're just going to
make like an arrow projectile so I'll
copy and paste this thing move it all
the way over here and let's let's just
make this arrow so I'll delete this I'm
just going to draw this black line here
just for now so I can see the bounds
okay so this arrow is gonna be pretty
beautiful um we're going
draw it in not on we're not gonna really
there aren't really any rules to follow
when you're drawing this by the way so
don't be too afraid I'm just gonna kind
of make it try to make it look good
which is always a struggle but you know
that looks terrible is that right that's
right I guess symmetrical and then we'll
give it a bit of like a tail you know
because that's what arrows look like all
right maybe one less how's that look
oh it's pretty good I think there you go
so there's our arrow it looks pretty
good so rotation right this is going to
be rotated now we can rotate this on any
degree that's how we're going to make
this we're not going to make it so that
we can only rotate it by 90 now this was
a very heavily requested topic I'm not
gonna lie sprite rotation was very very
very high up there in terms of how many
people asked for it okay and I of course
I do read the comments to my videos so I
was reading through some of my videos
and people were pointing out the fact
that it's pretty much impossible to do
because of the fact that you'll notice
that if I try and rotate this right if I
can even remember how to do it in
paint.net okay here we go so there's
there's this little rotation thing if I
rotate this yeah you will notice and let
me just change the quality of nearest
neighbors so that doesn't anti-alias it
if I rotate this you'll notice look
what's happening yeah if I rotate it 45
degrees or something close to that
look at that suddenly our sprite does
not take up our original size does it
yeah a few things have happened first of
all it's takes up more size right it's
wider and it's taller than it was before
second of all it looks like absolute
rubbish but we'll get to that later and
you'll also notice there are blank gaps
there avoid pixels that aren't there and
they're basically over here where I'm
just moving my mouse right now okay
three issues okay
the big one is the fact that it now
takes up more width so how are we gonna
solve that and we are it's very easy to
solve that Oh kale it's also very easy
to solve this problem the problem that
we actually cannot physically solve is
this okay this is kind of what it will
look like
all right unfortunately why because it's
just too low fidelity right it's just
too low resolution it isn't you we have
to deal with this okay
but nonetheless if you rotate it 90
degrees you can see it's perfect okay
and if we rotate it 90 degrees anyway
180 degrees whatever yeah it looks
pretty good
okay and I think our end game is gonna
probably look a bit better than this I
don't know why this looks so bad but the
point is with low resolution graphics
you're gonna get there's kind of a lot
of no problems so that's the idea okay
but the two things that we the people
were the seem to be afraid of was the
fact that you can see the sprite is now
bigger okay it's kind of spilling out of
its bounce so one thing I would just
recommend you guys to do when you're
drawing a sprites don't make them overly
big okay if you want them to be rotated
properly so don't make let's just say if
I I don't know why I'm drawing this
stuff in black and white but let's say I
just wanted like I don't know I had this
here for some reason you're gonna notice
that as I rotate this right it's
actually again I'm sorry it has to be
close to the UM my bad it has to be
close to the balance so I'm just gonna
continue drawing black and white here
but if I had something up here in the
corners basically like I don't know this
red kind of thing yeah like this red
thing here and I was to rotate this
sprite you guys gonna see that it's
gonna go off right it's just gonna go
off it's gonna go off the screen yeah so
just keep that in mind try and draw your
stuff to the center you can see that the
arrow the we drew is perfectly in
balance which is fantastic okay so we
don't need to worry about that but
that's just a heads up okay so I really
don't know what the people was I don't
know why you guys were so scared about
on about rotation in terms of spilling
out of bounds like I would have thought
that I taught you guys how to handle
out-of-bounds stuff and that's simply by
skipping those pixels and not rendering
them and not you know obviously just
yeah I mean clipping it I mean that's
really how simple it is and to do with
this we can just fill it in with a void
color that we can then make transparent
such as pink okay so don't worry this is
not that hard the algorithm is a bit
hard but we've kind of done already
oK we've subconsciously done it already
so I'm gonna put this arrow here now I
know this is in the wizard wizard
spritesheet so really I don't know why
it's this arrow is here but we're gonna
call this projectile arrow okay it's
gonna be in the wizard yeah just to save
time right you guys can organize a
surprise however you want obviously
doesn't really matter so the first thing
I want to do is actually get this in the
game yeah if I go into sprite essaouira
not sprite sheet sprite is what I meant
now selecting all the text what am i
doing well now I'm typing here it's been
a while since I made any videos on this
so projectile sprites here yeah we'll
copy and paste this will call this
projectile arrow okay we'll make sure it
is the first you can see this is 16 by
16 size pixel resolution passed it in
size pixel that's great 16 by 16 size
sprite okay that's pretty low res that's
why this rotation won't really look very
nice but it will still work that's
what's important and because the
projectiles are traveling that fast you
probably won't even notice
okay so pre our wizard and it's numb
spot number one so if we go back into
our wizard projectile which we fire
let's actually launch a game and see if
it even works here it doesn't and white
appeared on my monitor but here we go so
this says hey what's up guys my name is
Letourneau
great that's what I said at the
beginning of the video so we'll comment
that out so this font on Randall yeah
get that out of there and it keeps my
other monitor but anyway here we go yeah
this is what it looks like we're all
good there those are our projectiles
let's hop into wizard projectile and
change this to be projectile arrow so
now we're dealing with our new
projectile okay and there you go so
what's your narrows let's get rid of
that black border as well that black
line there that we had in um paint.net
so here we go go on alright fantastic so
now you should be seeing an arrow that
will is obviously not rotating right now
but we'll okay there yeah there's a very
fantastic so let's get into this how are
we gonna do this well
it is a graphical operation so I'm gonna
stick it in screen right now we could
stick in this bride and we'll see okay
we'll play around with this we'll get it
to work the way we want it to work but
first of all let's focus on actually
getting it in the game okay that's
always good so right now the way we read
projectiles is by calling a rendered
projectile this method right here I'm
gonna copy this method and I'm just
gonna add an angle now this angle is
going to be a double it's gonna be in
terms of radians okay where the reason
it's gonna be in radians and not in
degrees is pretty simple okay
wizard projectiles angle is stored
already in radians and also cosine once
radians and so the sine right all the
trigonometry operations want radians not
degrees and it's already in radians so
there's no point in having integrase
it's in radians and has to get used to
it okay okay
now over here though instead of getting
these sprite pixels we want to actually
physically rotate this sprite okay
throat a the sprite we're just gonna
modify its pixels now we're not going to
modify the sprites pixels okay we just
want to make a copy of them we don't
want to permanently modify them because
next time when we go to rotate it it's
already rotated okay apart from the fact
that sprites are static as you know
which is a good thing what I mean by
that is there is only one copy of this
projectile arrow in our entire game if
we rotate it and where we actually
modify it it's gonna be different for
the next entity that shoots okay so we
want to make a copy of these pixels so
straight away let's make a private
method here okay is going to be called
rotate it's going to return an integer
array which is gonna be the new pixels
that it creates okay it's gonna take in
the old pixels which are essentially the
non rotated sprite and it's gonna return
the rotated sprite it's gonna also take
in a bunch of important information such
as the width and height since we're not
passing in a sprite you know what we
could actually pass in a sprite honestly
but we're just gonna keep this nice and
simple okay so we're not gonna we're
gonna keep this very universal so it can
really act on any pixel all right
and finally we also need the angle we
actually need two more methods as well
just to make our lives easier but you'll
see that a bit later on okay so first of
all I like to start off methods by
writing what I really want
turn which is going to be the result
okay so the results can be a new a
completely new pixel array right a new
integer array with the same size as our
old one okay
width times height okay width times
height rolls to be the size of this now
how are we gonna call this pretty simple
okay it's gonna be pretty simple right
now we get the sprites pixels and then
we whatever we look up that index what
we want to do is instead of getting the
sprites pixels we're gonna get our own
pixels so I'm just gonna call our P our
pixels okay this is gonna be our rotated
pixels that's gonna equal we're gonna
grab this cut it it's gonna be rotate so
we're gonna rotate those pixels the
width and height is just simply going to
be P get sprite sighs I don't know why
we're using um get sprite dot size here
if we've got get anyway I don't know and
then the angle is obviously going to be
the angle that we specify here okay in
radians so there's our pixels we're
gonna replace them with this over here
and now essentially we're just dealing
with rotate okay that's good that's all
done now if we were to run this it will
give us a black because all these
integers will be automatically
initialize to zero by Java okay anyway
let's get started with the rotation so
we actually need more methods we need
two methods okay one's gonna basically
deal with the X side of rotation and one
is gonna deal with the Y side of
rotation okay I'm not gonna hand execute
and basically explain this step-by-step
because it will take too long but I will
give you guys a rough idea of how it
works
and it's really not that hard okay it it
might seem that way but it's not so
first of all we'll be returning I'll
just call this rotation X okay I know
I'm kind of breaking the Java Convention
LLC I don't so you think it looks better
this way
but rotation axis okay so this is going
to it's you can see it returns a double
okay this is very similar to how we do
projectiles okay when you think about it
when you think about it right what are
we really trying to do when we rotate
we're trying to let's just say we're
rotating by 45 degrees okay if I copy
and paste this and I were to rotate this
by about 45 degrees well that's exactly
45 degrees there
right that's what I've done what's
actually happening well we're taking and
I'm going to just use a different color
for this maybe like green we're taking
let's just say this pixel over here and
we want to move we want to rotate it by
45 degrees so we want to put it just
about there okay what are we actually
doing to it
can you guys notice what's happening to
that pixel how is it moving
well it's moving these nodes moving
right and then down okay so it's
actually physically moving now what
angle is it moving on roughly okay it's
moving on negative 45 degrees okay
that's the angle that is moving in we
want us to rotate it 45 degrees
clockwise which means it goes negative
45 now why is that way negative that's
one question I actually get quite a lot
so I'm going to ask that real quick if
you guys are not familiar with the unit
circle get familiar with the unit circle
okay if you've done maths in like high
school or whatever you you probably know
what I'm talking about okay and this is
what the unit circle looks like let me
just show this real quick here I wasn't
planning on showing this but you know
what I thought it was important enough
this is what the unit circle looks like
all right now what you'll notice and
what really is important for us is the
fact that zero degrees you can see is
right
okay that's zero degrees it's on that
way positive 90 degrees is this way okay
270 degrees is over here it's also if we
go negative obviously we're going down
so that's why we're going negative okay
a lot of people think zero degrees is up
it's not okay 90 degrees is up zero
degrees is just horizontally right okay
down is either 270 degrees 3 PI over 2
radians or negative PI over 2 radians or
negative 90 degrees okay
so thus when we go this way we're going
negative 45 degrees that's the angle
okay now do we know how to move pixels
based on angles yeah we do that's what
that's how our entire project our system
works right in our projectile system
look at this NX and NY what do we do we
take the cosine of the angle and that's
our new X or that's the DX that's the
Delta X that's the direction along the x
axis where we actually move to
okay and all we do to move our
projectile is move it by that amount
every frame okay or not every frame but
every update all right that's how it
works
this is the same way that this is gonna
work all right
there's nothing cryptic about this we're
going to send this pixel and move it
negative 45 degrees that way because
we've rotated it by 45 degrees and even
I can't even right 45 degrees this
resolution so there you go
that explains the bad rotation but
that's that's the idea all right
does that make sense I really hope that
makes sense but that's the that's
basically how it works okay if we
rotated 90 degrees obviously that pixel
was going to be somewhere I don't know
here okay and you'll see it like you if
we rotate it you'll see that alright but
the idea is you can see that we've moved
at negative 45 degrees all right that's
the idea yeah so the first thing you'll
notice is well you'll notice a lot of
things but if we rotated clockwise we
want for festival we want to say that we
want to say that clockwise is positive I
know that goes against seen it circle
but when we think about about this like
as a human we think clockwise if I
rotate this 90 degrees I'm not rotating
it I'm not rotating it this way yeah
that to me looks like negative 90 even
though technically it is positive 90
okay so we want to reverse this that's
why we're going to need to use negative
angle so you'll see me use negative
angle quite a lot here that's why okay
it's because we're kind of overriding
the unit circle and doing our own
rotation thus if we want this to be
positive if we write 45 degrees for this
it's actually negative 45 does we need a
negative angle okay but that's how this
works so how do we figure out the Delta
X Delta Y whatever you want to call the
variables NX n 1u x nu y how do we
figure out where to move that pixel
there's where these methods come in
rotation X we'll figure out where to
move it on the x axis now this is going
to take in a few things it's gonna take
in the angle all right it's going to
return a double which is gonna be the
new position of the X essentially based
on that it's not even it's not even
gonna be that though
because will actually do the animation
in rotate itself all right and by
animation I mean the the moving of this
pixel down to this pixel all right
but what this will do is simply return
either okay this is where this comes in
as well
we'll put double X&Y now these are not
the positions these are whether or not
we essentially want to do it on each
axis okay I don't know it's weird
because your rotation X but as x and y
but you know we'll get into that don't
stress too much so the cosine is gonna
be very simple it can only map cosine
now we don't need to convert it into
degrees it's already in sorry we don't
need committed into radians it's not in
degrees is already in radians so we
simply pump in the angle here and we're
good to go now there will be one more
adjustment we have to make but we'll do
that later after I demonstrate this as
it is right now
so we'll return X multiplied by the
cosine okay plus y times negative sine
all right and how does this work this
works exactly the same way that basic I
don't know basic angular motion kind of
works right going incrementing variables
based on a pixel and separating the axes
to get it in terms of x and y
essentially converting kind of vectors
into more or less point space well we're
actually dealing with X&Y rather than a
direction and a length which is kind of
what a vector is anyway getting back to
this we've got a rotation X we've got a
rotation Y now this is gonna be the same
I'm at least these two are gonna be the
same this is gonna be slightly different
all right
X connects is gonna be x sine and Y is
gonna be more x positive cosine all
right
simple that's the way it works okay that
is how we can translate all that's
really all we need to get the direction
for X&Y
of this okay I mean we've got the
direction but to get the I guess the
absolute position the new absolute
position of it okay so back in result go
back in rotate rather with result what
we're gonna do is we're gonna have to
figure out a few things
first of all we need a new position we
need a new x and y position for this
pixel all right so this pixel has two
coordinates x and y right we need the NX
or the i guess the amount we need to
move by we don't know we need to
basically know the direction okay we
don't know how far we want to move it
yet that's what the four loops that
we'll see later we'll figure out this
will tell us the direction it needs to
movement so negative 45 right that's
what we kind of figured it out to be so
I don't know what to call this I'll call
it probably something like NX I mean I
will go with NX just because we chose it
here okay but this is going to be the x
coordinate of the X okay which is gonna
sound a bit tricky but don't worry it's
gonna use rotation axes gonna use
negative angle right I explain why it's
because of the unit circle and the way
that we perceive this this is going to
be one point zero this is going to be
zero point zero now you'll notice that
if we make Y zero point zero it's gonna
completely cancel out Y because Y
multiplied by negative 0 or Y multiplied
by zero is zero so that's really x times
cosine okay that's how we can use this
alright so that was a we will only
interested in the x coordinate now this
is the y coordinate all right so the y
coordinate is actually gonna look
exactly the same except it's gonna use
rotations Y okay two more of these so
now we need them to do for the Y pixels
all right so we're just gonna literally
switch the names just like that and then
over here we're gonna switch this to be
on the Y so it'll cancel out the X okay
pretty pretty smart if I do say so
myself
all right there you go that's that's a
it's not like I created this I mean this
is really common stuff to do but that's
the idea now finally what we actually
need is an initial rotation pixel value
okay to do that I mean watch is what its
gonna call this x0 I think I'm running
out of names here because we also need
to the integer conversion so there's
also doubt but we'll set this equal to
rotation X and this will be negative
angle as well but this is going to be a
bit
all right it's gonna be negative width
divided by 2 negative heights / - this
is probably the most complex part of
this entire algorithm and plus width
divided by 2 okay
and the y version of that is gonna be
kind of simple as well it's going to be
rotation Y obviously and it's gonna be
the exact same except we're going to add
on ice / - instead of width okay what is
this going to do okay
that's the tricky part this is going to
be the initial value of the pixel before
we add on all of our actual direction or
directional vectors okay this is the
initial value of it okay
based on the angle now where this goes
and what not this kind of depends on
after service this kind of depends on
the source pixel okay so all the all the
colors are yeah remember all oldest all
the stuff that's in pixels that's just a
bunch of colors so they're really the
only reason we need this original pixels
arrays just to see which color but when
you think about it we know the size we
know where we want to rotate it - yeah
so we don't need color for that we don't
need this pixels array at all the only
reason is there is so that we know which
color to put where okay but the point is
we don't need it to figure out
rotational vectors and whatnot okay we
know that it doesn't matter what is
inside these bounds yeah
if I rotate at 45 degrees it's gonna it
doesn't care what's inside okay that is
what this does that's why it's just in
some number play okay now we get to the
actual rotation so we know we know the
initial positions we know the vet the
positional there I should really call
them vectors because they're separated
but we know the the the separate x and y
directions for travel essentially so now
what we need to do is actually go
through the for loop that will move the
Pixlr to the right location yeah so we
figured out this this is essentially X
x0 and y0 we figured out this that's
where I mean we haven't figure out this
yet that's what the full loop we'll do
in a minute but we figured out which
direct
this lies in and how much we need to
move on the X&Y okay so now all that's
left is to actually move this into here
all right so how are we doing that well
we'll make a nested for loop here it's
gonna do this for every pixel in our
array so this is gonna be width by
height as I'm sure you guys are aware
all right now I am gonna make X 1 and X
1 and Y ones just because it will meet
them and you guys will see that in a
minute but basically they're just copies
of the initial starting locations
because we're going to animate it now so
to animate it based on X and remember we
have to animate a boson both on x and y
this is just gonna do it for the row so
the road if we look at the first row
yeah that's gonna get rotated and become
somewhere here so obviously both the x
and y position changes hence we need the
x and y so the first row yeah well
that's what's gonna happen to that is
essentially okay let me do that how I
wanna write this to explain it better
first of all let's just convert them
into integers right x1 and y1 convert
them into images because wait for me to
draw them in terms of introduce the
reason I've got them as doubles as
obviously because all these operations
are using sine and cosine and we want
them to be fairly precise and I made a
massive mistake here make sure this says
sign okay so we got the sines and the
cosines obviously so we'll Wow so yet so
they deal with sine and cosine obviously
we want some pretty high level precision
and in the end we just committed into an
integer so that we can actually draw it
since pixels and can't have half pixels
or whatever they need to be interested
especially because this is an integer
right okay we've got that now so what we
essentially want to do is set a variable
here we what we just want to really set
the result right now what index in the
result X Y times width all right pretty
basic stuff same way we draw it yeah
this is an accent this is a simple with
height X Y array sorry for loop
structure thing so we obviously just
wanted wrong
way and then we just set that equal to
color okay what is the color the color
is just based on the original array now
what index in the array though it's
gonna be our rotated index that's what
we're trying to figure out yeah we
already know what the wooden heart of
the new one's gonna be all we want to do
is basically move this pixel right and
the way we move the pixel is we figure
out we figure out the index of this
pixel based on where it is in the old
array and copy it into the new location
in the new array okay that's how it
works
that was a mouthful to say a bit so X X
plus y Y and guess what the width is
gonna remain the same isn't it we're not
changing the width so the width friends
are saying the only thing that changes
is the actual index okay and that's
gonna be well the X&Y coordinate I
should say cuz the whole thing's an
index and that's gonna be based on our
calculations here so that's the result
yeah all we do is we increment X Y x1
and y1 which are the ones we use kind of
for X here we increment them based on
the direction
that's it so NX underscore X is what we
use here and NX underscore Y okay so you
can see the first kind of thing refers
to this for loop okay so the for the
next one we'll use and YY and n YX and n
YY okay but that's the idea here at the
end of this same thing exactly except
it's on x0 so we're animating this okay
based on the Y so this is gonna be
Horace the vertical pixels alright
that's it this is basically the entire
algorithm okay it's quite simple few
errors okay first of all we don't clip
this so we will get index out of bounds
exception okay secondly we don't do
anything with the board pixel so there's
two problems with this that we need to
figure out it's gonna be a very long
episode I'm considering breaking this up
into two actually I probably will okay
so we'll get the basic stuff working and
then we'll let's put it up next next
episode so because I really wanted to
get my explanation down on this because
I know a lot of you guys got I mean
really interested so this is uh
so we've done this right but you can see
that we spill out of the bounce so we
need to cover that so how do do we know
what the bounds are absolutely less than
zero and greater than with okay less
than zero and greater than height yeah
we know that stuff so what we do is we
say that if X X so it's easy to detect
right if X X is less than zero and
access X X X X is greater than or equal
to width okay with being the width about
sprite make sure it's not if you call
this something different make sure you
don't go distant width or basically that
whole thing or basically if you call
this W make sure you make it with we um
we do on the field we don't want the
width of our actual window I get which
is this width we want to make sure is
the width of the sprite that's what
we're interested in okay and while I is
less than zero wise doesn't read it I it
so it's easy easy to detect but then
what do we do so now we have to decide
I'm gonna say where's gonna give it kind
of like a void color okay so like pink
for example pink is kind of like our
transparent color or a basically current
I'll call that will be transparent okay
so let's set up a color variable we'll
just set it equal to zero for now here
we'll set it equal to pink okay which is
FF 0 0 FF in terms of a 24-bit our RGB
color with a one byte per channel or
eight bits per channel that's that right
and otherwise though yeah otherwise so
else if it doesn't exceed the bounds
then we'll set the color equal to this
because these are the bounds that we're
worried about exceeding so I'll put that
here okay and obviously here we'll set
it equal to color whatever that color
may be either pink if it's void or the
actual real color if it's actually
within bounds
done okay simple as that that solves two
problems the clipping so now this will
get clipped okay
and it also solves some let me just so
this will get clipped now there you go
clipped nice clipping animation for you
guys moving that thing come on work with
me here
no it doesn't wanna move okay
she the our case it's gonna clip that
right well it's not gonna this is
actually part of this but anyway and
it's also got to make sure that all of
these white spaces that result from the
rotation yeah or in this case I guess
you'd call them the transparent parts
yeah they will become pink
it'll fill it in with pink alright there
you go done okay
simple as that let's test this out in
action so what we want to do I let's see
this in action I should say what we want
to do here well actually actually
already set it up haven't we so all we
need to do really is go back to wizard
projectile and change the angle to be
referred to use the new render method
alright and now let's launch it and see
what we see so if I go up over here and
I try and fire okay
so we're getting a bunch of pink things
so and then there's our arrow so clearly
we've done something wrong here so let's
go back into the code and see what we
missed all right so let's see and it
looks like so usually so make sure this
is of sex y1 and why whatever usually
all these problems by the way when you
get good I guess experience at debugging
you'll notice that usually the problem
stamp for me from you if there's two
components like x and y you just forget
to actually use the proper versions yeah
so I put x1 twice instead of x1 and y1
and that was problem okay so if we
launch this again what we'll see is
check this out so it's working okay it
looks really weird because it looks like
this is going sideways that's one thing
I won't really want to do actually is go
to wizard projectile and slow down the
size to one so the speed is fought and
on the size the speed the speed was four
let's put it down a1 here real quick and
if we go over here someone working on
Sam we shoot you can see it's it's
correct yes what's it is rotated yeah
it's just it looks like it's just not
rotated properly alright and this comes
down to exactly the way it works if we
cast it right yeah what is
looks like weird arrow but right is zero
degrees based on the unit circle that I
showed you guys right that's zero
degrees so well we kind of want that to
be zero degrees in a way and then that
there's that pink void stuff that I was
talking about right so there it is and
then the other parts are just getting
clipped which is fantastic we don't get
any index N and there is ever so really
the problem is we want to offset the
rotation how do we do that well the
easiest way to do that is just to go
into screen here and instead of going by
angle we'll rotate it how much do we
want to rotate it by we're gonna rotate
it by negative 90 degrees okay because
if we look at this yeah and we um we
fire right yeah we want it to be rotated
clockwise and remember clockwise is
negative on the unit circle so that's
negative 90 degrees negative 90 degrees
is equivalent to PI over 2 radians okay
or half of pi radians okay so we simply
go math two pi divided by two in our
rotation X and rotation Y and that'll
just essentially get us to the right
thing we could have also done this in
the angle for Blizzard projectile but I
thought since this is going to apply to
pretty much any anything we do it's
better just to put it here in the actual
method so if we go back to this thing
and we try and launch it you'll see that
I'll look at that that arrow is heading
in that direction and everything looks
fantastic again the rotation looks kind
of weird sometimes but if we do put the
speed up to four then you'll see that
really it's kind of hard to actually
notice that the arrow looks weird okay
the other thing we get is the pink stuff
I'm sure you guys know how to remove
that right all we need to do is simply
say in the color here that if color
doesn't equal our Alpha color that's
actually already in there it's just that
our alpha color is set to have a have an
alpha Channel I mean it's even called
alpha color so we should probably go
down here and add the FF at the front
right the reason I did this way is just
so that you can actually see the pink
stuff that was getting added in based on
the voice stuff and now you can see we
don't get it so there you go there is
our rotation now there's a very kind of
a big problem with it's not really a big
problem but there's one thing stopping
this from being perfect and that is
performance okay if we check this out
when we go into multiple mobs firing if
you look at the frame rate I mean I just
dropped to about 60 frames per second
okay if you look here in the bottom of
the screen and if I get out of here
obviously we'll go back up to like 3000
yeah there you go so what's the problem
the problem is this rotation method is
being called in a nested for loop every
frame for a projectile that is an insane
amount of times okay if I was to quickly
measure how often this rotate method was
actually called room this rotation
measure that method isn't isn't a walk
in the park
it calls external method methods like 6
times right these two methods which of
cosine calculations and it's got a
nested for loop that copies and modifies
everything in here ok that's a lot of
calls okay that's a lot of data to
actually process and this rotate method
if I was just to quickly measure how
often it actually runs how many times
per second so we'll go wrote a plus plus
here we'll make a static integer here
we'll go back to game and inside here
while we print the per second kind of
stuff we'll add in so we'll just go
screen wrote a plus per second all right
and then we'll set it equal to zero when
we're done with that if we look at this
and I go down here look at that that is
absolutely ludicrous check this out
1 over 1 million times per second over a
million times per second and it looks
like it went no less than 780,000 okay
that is ridiculous we do not want to
call such a heavy expensive algorithm
that many times especially because we
don't need it that many times once an
arrow is thrown its Direction never
changes
okay it stays on that constant
okay so what we're gonna do next time is
avoid doing a damage look if I fart it's
not right now zone zero per second if I
fire an arrow 174,000 per second
yeah straight away that's absolutely
ridiculous so we don't want to do that
all right so next time we're gonna fix
that up and make sure it doesn't do
every frame if you guys enjoyed this
video please hit the like button it
really helps me out and of course it
lets me know that you guys are looking
forward to these videos and motivates me
to do more if you guys have any
questions be sure to post them in the
comments below or on my forum and I'll
see you guys hopefully like in like two
days or so where the new episode again
programming so yeah how are you today
guys good bye
you